GOOD MORNING I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S PROP NISSIM SORRY
I'M LATE- WELCOME TO THE US
BOOKS USING. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS
HEARING IT IN PERSON IS
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES ROLE IN THE BUILDING WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TODAY. IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL.
PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY PROMPT TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM CHORE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. FOR DIALING WITNESSES WHO
WERE USING THE MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
THE PUBLIC CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
DO SO WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON BEGINS A
BILL PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE PHONE SERVICE PLEASE
CALL OUR COMMITTEE ONE. A
916-319-3958 MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU WE ALSO ACCEPT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL. AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE CONTINUE USING
METHODS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE STILL
FACE. SALAS NOW COVER A FEW THE
GROUND RULES FOR APPROPRIATE
CONDUCT. THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED SOME DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISFRUTEN DE DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE TALKING MAKE MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. SPEAKING
LONGER THAN TIME ALONE ALLOTTED.
AND EXTENDED DISCUSSION MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR THE BILL. AND ANY
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS TO
ADDRESS- TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS ARE HEARING
PROCESS I WOULD RECKON TO STOP
AND WANT THEM TO CONTINUE. THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT
IN THE- REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITAL
. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE
RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED
AND THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT. AND I'M HI
MAY TEMPORARILY RE RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST ASSISTANCE
WHEN SERGEANT IN ESCORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY ONE OF THESE
ITEMS HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE
AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
NINETEEN TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA HAS BEEN PULLED.
AND ONE OF THE AGENDAITEMS AS
PER FOR PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO ZERO
ONE FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY. WE WILL HEAR ALL OTHER
BILLS IN THE ORDER SHOWN ON THE
AGENDA UNLESS OTHERWISE NOTED.
WE WILL TAKE UP TO PAY WE WILL
TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND UP TO TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL. OF THE
CIVIL COURT ROOM ONE. TWO THREE
NO WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET
RIGHT. OKAY SO- WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND OUR FIRST ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA IS A. B. SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE MATTERS
HERE- TO- THIS. COMMITTEE I
THANK FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH AIDS-
WHICH SEEKS TO SEPARATE CORNERS
OFFICE FROM THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BEFORE
I BEGIN I WANT TO RESPECTFULLY
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT. THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED WHICH
WOULD REMOVE LINE TWENTY FIVE ON
PAGE THREE THAT READS TAX
COLLECTOR- CORNER. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY ONE OF THE OF THE
THREE STATES THAT STILL ALLOWS-
COUNTIES TO COMBINE THE OFFERS
OF THE CORONER'S OFFICE WITH THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT MEMBERS WE
ARE LATE AT THE PARTY. RELATE TO
THE PARTY WHY IS THAT THIS
QUESTION THIS IS A QUESTION- WE
SHOULD AT WE SHOULD BE ASKING.
FOR YEARS WE HAVE WITNESSED. FAR
TOO MANY TRAGEDIES. AND PATTERNS
OF INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
SHERIFF'S. ARLE ARE ALLOWING- TO
OVERSEE HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
OVERSEE CAUSES OF DEATH RULINGS
. THIS HAS RESULTED IN BIAS
MEDICAL INVESTIGATION TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. ANGELO CANTO. OSCAR
GRANT. MAL'S HALL. DAVID SILVER
. CHRISTIAN AYE SINGER. AND THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON. THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE FAMILIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LEFT WITHOUT ANSWERS.
WITH EMPTINESS IN THEIR HEARTS.
A. B. SIXTEEN OH EIGHT. WHAT PUT
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH THE REST
OF THE STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
ADVANCED A SIMILAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LIKE AB SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA TEN COUNTIES
ARE ALREADY DOING- WHAT AB
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT SEEKS TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE TODAY CHALDEANS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SEPARATED.
LIKE LOS ANGELES. INYO
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO SAN JOAQUIN MET SAN
MATEO SANTA CLARA VENTURA. I AM
PROUD TO SAY THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
INTRODUCED A MOTION TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH EIGHT.
BOTH OF THESE COUNTIES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY INDEPENDENT
FUNCTIONS. MEMBERS CURRENT STATE
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE A STATE A.
SHARES TO HAVE WATCH THIS ANY
MEDICAL BACKGROUND OR
CERTIFICATION TO ASSUME THE
DUTIES OF A CORNER OFFICE NO ONE
UNDERSCORE THAT. AS A RESULT IT
HAS CAUSED MANY TO QUESTION
WHETHER THE MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS IS
BALLOT WHEN THERE IS AN OFFICER
INVOLVED. SHOOTING OR DEATH THAT
OCCURS. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT. FROM TWO BILLS FROM TWO
BILLS AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX AND
A. B. FOUR NINETY WHICH I WROTE.
THIS GOVERNOR GAVIN IS THE
SIGNED BOTH BILLS INTO LAW IN
LIGHT OF THE TRAGEDY AND THE
DEATH AND THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD AND ANGELO KINKO. IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR ANGELO
CAME TO A UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED BY POLICE
. ANGELO CANTALOUPES CASE EIGHT
MONTHS AFTER HIS DEATH THE
CONTRA COSTA CORONER'S OFFICE
ISSUED A REPORT B. FOR THE
AUTOPSY. AND RULED THE DEATH AS
ACCIDENTAL AND LISTED THE CAUSE
OF DEATH WATCH THIS EXCITED
DELIRIUM. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
EXCITED DELIRIUM. I GET EXCITED
ALL THE TIME. BUT THEY CONCLUDED
IT WAS EXCITED DELIRIUM THE TERM
EXCITED DELIRIUM IS REJECTED BY
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
AMERICANS OFF THE PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION THIS TERM HAS BEEN
REJECTED BY THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AT LARGE YET IT IS
STILL USED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
EXPLAIN CERTAIN DEATHS OCCURRING
IN POLICE CUSTODY. IN FACT
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE OUTSIDE
THE POSITIONS OF HUMAN RIGHTS
RELEASED A REPORT DEEP BALL TEAM
THIS TERM AND I PROVIDED COPIES
FOR EACH OF YOU TO LOOK AT THE
RESEARCH AND WHY THEY CONCLUDE
IT WHAT THEY CONCLUDED THUS FAR
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY IT WASN'T
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SEPARATED THE DUTIES. OF THE
SHERIFFS AND THE CORONER'S
OFFICE IT TOOK A VERY PUBLIC AND
EMBARRASSING RESIGNATION FROM
THE CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER'S.
AND ANOTHER MEDICAL EXAMINER ON
STAFF FOR THE COUNTY TO ACT OVER
THE NINE MONTH PERIOD THE CHIEF
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S DOCUMENTED.
COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF AUTOPSIES
THEY PERFORMED. THESE
DOCUMENTATIONS INCLUDES INSTANCE
DENSE INSTANCES WHEN THE SHERIFF
CHANGED THEIR CAUSE OF DEATH
FINDINGS ACCORDING TO THE
DOCUMENTATION IN SOME CASES THEY
FELT PRESSURED BY THE SHERIFF'S
TO REPORT SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE THESE ARE
ONE OF TWO STARK EXAMPLES THAT
EXPLAINS WHY WE SHOULD WE SHOULD
NOT WAIT UNTIL A LIFE IS LOS WAR
UNTIL ANOTHER SITUATION HAPPENS
LIKE I JUST DESCRIBED. WE CAN
CHANGE THIS TRAJECTORY NOW IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO QUESTION
WHAT DOES NOT TRULY MAKES SENSE. MEMBERS JOINING ME TODAY- TO
MY LEFT IS DOCTOR ROGER MITCHELL
THE CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER
OFFICER FROM WASHINGTON DC WHO
ALSO CONCLUDED CONDUCTED SKEWS
WE CONDUCTED THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AUDIT OF SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY IN ADDITION WE WILL HAVE-
JOINING ME SANDRA AKITO COLLINS
THE MOTHER OF ANGELO TO BELLA.
CANTO AND WHICH IS THE SISTER OF
AGILE KATO AND ROBERT COLLINS
THE STEPFATHER OF ANGELO KEEN TO
WHO WILL- TESTIFIED. DR. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY- COMMITTEE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THANK YOU FOR-
ASSEMBLY GIBSON FOR YOUR
INVITATION IT'S MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
HERE TODAY. I'M DOCTOR ROGER
MITCHELL JUNIOR ON THE BOARD
CERTIFIED FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS
AND ANATOMIC PATHOLOGIST AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN AWAIT.
THAT STRIVES TO DEFINITIVELY
SEPARATE THE OFFICE OF THE
CORNER RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
SHERIFF. I'M A FORMER FBI
FORENSIC SCIENTISTS. ACTICIN
FORENSIC PATHOLOGY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN I WAS THE
CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER FOR
WASHINGTON DC FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AT TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE I'VE PERFORMED NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND AUTOPSIES IN MY CAREER
THE LATEST WAS JUST THIS PAST
SATURDAY- AND I HAVE. EXPERTISE
THAT EXPANDS GLOBALLY CURRENTLY
I AM A TENURED PROFESSOR AND
CHAIR OF PATHOLOGY AT HOWARD
UNIVERSITY COLLEGE OF MEDICINE.
I SPENT MUCH OF MY CAREER
DESCRIBING DEATH IN CUSTODY AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAD A GROUP OF MEDICAL
EXAMINERS ON A POSITION PAPER
AND DEATH IN CUSTODY THE PAPER
OUTLINES A SERIES OF GUIDELINES
FOR THE PROPER INVESTIGATION
EXAMINATION. AND REPORTING OF
THESE CASES MANY OF YOU MAY BE
AWARE OF THE TRANSITION OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY FROM A
SHERIFF CORNER SYSTEM TO A
MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM. I WAS
CALLED IN BY THAT COUNTY TO
PERFORM THE AUDIT THAT LED TO
ITS SEPARATION. THAT AUDIT IS
NOW PUBLIC RECORD. I COME HERE
TO SERVE AS A RESOURCE FOR YOU.
AS YOU MAKE THIS CRITICAL
DECISION TO SEPARATE THE OFFICES
OF THE CORNER FROM THE SHERIFF
IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL WILL GO
A LONG WAY TOWARDS INSTILLING
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN DEATH
INVESTIGATION PARTICULARLY THOSE
DEATHS THAT OCCUR IN CONNECTION
WITH THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
EITHER DURING ARREST TRANSPORT.
OR WHILE IN JAIL BUT NOT ONLY
THAT. WITH PROPERLY STAFFED AND
TRAINED MEDICAL LEGAL DEATH
INVESTIGATION SYSTEM
CALIFORNIANS CAN RELY ON THE
REPORTED DATA OF ALL TYPES OF
DEATHS INCLUDING SUDDEN AND
UNEXPECTED NATURAL DEATHS DEATHS
OF MOMS WHO DIED WHILE IN LABOR.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
DEATHS TO COLBY. AND EVEN TODAY
DEATHS DUE TO MASS FATALITY. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE CALLED FOR
THE STRENGTHENING OF THE MEDICAL
LEGAL DEATH INVESTIGATION SYSTEM
PART OF THAT REPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE CALLED FOR THE
REMOVAL OF THE SHERIFF CORNER
SYSTEM. OUT OF THE LACK OF
EXPERTISE LET ME BE CLEAR. WE
SHOW SUPPORT OF OUR SHERIFFS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT BY SEPARATING
THE CORNER FUNCTION. THE CORNER
SYSTEM THE UNITED STATES WAS
IMPORTED HERE WITH THE ORIGINAL
COLONIZATION ATTEMPTS AT
IMPROVEMENT OF THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN OCCURRING SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. BUT IS YET TO BE
COMPLETELY MATURE INTO THE
SYSTEM IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BE. AB ONE SIX ZERO EIGHT ö
SMALL BUT NECESSARY STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING THAT HEALTH EQUITY IN
DEATH THAT WE ALL PURSUE IN
LIFE. BY PROVIDING RELIABLE
REPRODUCIBLE TIMELY AND ACCURATE
DEATH INVESTIGATION YOU ARE
GIVING CLARITY AND CLOSURE TO
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES IN THE
MOST DEVASTATING TIME OF NEED.
YOUR DECISION TODAY WILL HAVE
GREATER POSITIVE IMPACT THAN YOU
COULD EVER IMAGINE. I'M TRULY
PROUD OF THIS AUSPICIOUS BODY
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO MAKE
THIS CHANGE. SEPARATE THE
SHERIFF IN THE CORNER SYSTEM
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE OTHER I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
. YES WE CAN SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THE WORK TO OF THE STATUS OF
QUORUM RIGHT NOW WHILE WE GET
THE OTHER- WITNESSES UP. GOOD
POINT MISTER. SECRETARY
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
PRESENT LACKEY LACKEY PRESENT
BLOOM HERE WILL PRESENT
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
PRESIDENT RAMOS. RAMOS PRESIDENT
THREE OF US THREE OF US
PRESERVATIONISTS VOEPEL YEAH
VOEPEL PRESIDENT. OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR-
OF THE SUPPORTERS ON THE BILL
TOGETHER WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
MINUTES IS THAT OKAY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO START. GOOD
MORNING WE NEED THIS CONSENT TO
KEEP THE COLLINS. THIS IS PAULA
THIS IS ROBERT WE ARE THE FAMILY
OF FANS OF THE KINGDOM. MY SON
ANGELO SKILLED IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY WAY ANTIOCH POLICE
OFFICERS IN FRONT OF ME ON MY
BEDROOM FLOOR. HE WAS
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT LATE. BUT HE WAS NOT
VIOLENT DID NOT HAVE ANY WEAPONS
. IN WAS NOT UNDER THE INFLUENCE
OF ANY COMMON DRUGS. SUBSTANCES
OF ABUSE DESPITE THE OFFICERS
ACKNOWLEDGING ALL OF THIS THE
PLACE TO BE ON THE STOMACH ON
THE GROUND. HANDCUFFED HIM
PUSHED HIS CROSSED LEGS AGAINST
HIS BACK IN NEIL NEIL ON THE
BACK OF HIS NECK DURING AT LEAST
A FOUR AND  HALF MINUTES OF
JUST RESTRAINT HE WAS COMPLETELY
UNRESPONSIVE. YES STRING LAST AT
LEAST THE LAST FOUR AND A HALF
MINUTES MISTER STREET IS
COMPLETELY UNRESPONSIVE- SOON
AFTER HE WAS KILLED WE
EXPERIENCED BLATANT DECEIT FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND- WE WERE
LATER TOLD BY OUR LAWYERS THAT.
THIS DEATH WOULD BE BLAMED ON
EXCITED DELIRIUM- WHICH WE KNOW
IS WIDELY MEDICALLY DENOUNCED-
AND STATISTICALLY OFTEN LIKE 90%
OF THE TIME USED IN CASE OF IN
CUSTODY DEATHS- AND- SO. WE
SOUGHT A AN INDEPENDENT
PATHOLOGIST TO CONDUCT AN
OBJECTIVE AUTOPSY- AND- AT THE
EIGHT MONTHS LATER AT THE AT
WHAT IS CALLED THE CORONER'S
INQUEST THE CORONER- UNDER THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE SHERIFF DID IN
FACT RULE HIS DEATH TO BE
EXCITED DELIRIUM- WE WERE. THAT
DAY AT THE CORONER'S INQUEST WAS
EYE OPENING IT WAS- ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLE WE WERE WITNESS TO
A LOT OF BIAS- THEY FOR EXAMPLE
DID NOT NAME US AS WITNESSES
EVEN THOUGH MY MOTHER WAS IN THE
ROOM THE ENTIRE TIME MY BROTHER
WAS BEING KILLED AND I WAS IN
THE HALLWAY GOING BACK AND
FORTH- THE- CONTRADICTED PUBLIC
MEDICAL RECORDS- THEY HAD VERY
LITTLE EVIDENCE FOR EXCITED
DELIRIUM IF WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
IT IS IF IT IS LEGITIMATE. AND-
THE HEARING OFFICER. VERY
BLATANTLY LED THE WITNESSES TO
SAY SPECIFIC THINGS FILLED IN
WHEN THEY WERE MISSING
SOMETHING- AND I'LL STOP RIGHT
THERE BERMAN OTHER THINGS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU- I'M
ROBERT COLLINS. YOU KNOW THEY
WERE TO CRIMES COMMITTED THAT
NIGHT ON DECEMBER TWENTIETH OCT
TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WAS THE EXCESSIVE FORCE THAT WAS
USED IN ANGELO WHICH IS A
COMPLETE UNNECESSARY. BUT THE
SECOND CRIME WAS THE CRIME OF
COVERING UP A COVER UP THAT
BEGAN IMMEDIATELY THE FAMILY
HEARD THE NEXT- A FEW DAYS LATER
CONTACTING THE ATTORNEY. THAT AN
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES WAS ALMOST
A NECESSITY BECAUSE- WE DON'T
HAVE TRUST IN THE SYSTEM. TO BE
IMPARTIAL WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
AN AB SIXTY NO EIGHT. S. TO
CHANGE THE ROLE SO THAT THE
SHERIFF IS NOT OVERSEEING WHICH
SHOULD BE A SCIENTIFIC AND
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS BECAUSE EVEN
IF THERE'S ONLY A PERCEPTION OF
BIAS THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
GOVERNMENT SHOULD HAVE ARE IN
ITS OPERATIONS WE WANT THE
PUBLIC TO TRUST THE SYSTEMS THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY CANNOT BE
TRUSTED WHEN THOSE INCREASE ARE
SUBJECT TO- TO THE AUTHORITY OF
A SHERIFF HOW IT MAY HAVE BEEN
CENTS A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AGO
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WAY.
SO IT'S REALLY A COMMONSENSE
REFORM. AND IT BRINGS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
OBJECTIVITY AND BELIEVE ME OUR
FAMILY HAS DEFINITELY SEEN. HOW
THIS PROCESS WAS NOT OBJECTIVE
TRANSPARENT- OR UNBIASED. IN OUR
CASE IT WAS SO CLEAR THEY
CONTRADICTED HOSPITAL RECORDS
THAT CONTRADICTED EVERYTHING
THEY IGNORED SO MUCH EVIDENCE-
IT'S JUST SO PATENTLY CLEAR SO.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR I THINK IS
A VERY COMMON SENSE REFORM AND I
THINK YOU'RE DOING IT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
ALL BE ABLE TO RELY ON.
ASSISTANCE GOVERNMENT- SO I SAID
THERE WERE TWO CRIMES COMMITTED.
BUT BY PASSING THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION YOU MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES LIKE OURS CAN GET
CLOSURE. AND CAN MOVE BEYOND THE
TRAGEDY THAT'S HAPPENED INSTEAD
OF LIVING THE NIGHTMARE OF.
TRYING TO- COMBAT AND CARE FIVE
WHAT'S WRONG WITH GOVERNMENT. SO
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY-
I THINK YOU'RE HAVING A GREAT
IMPACT ON MANY LIVES LIVES THAT
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW BECAUSE NOT
EVERYONE CAN AFFORD AND IN THE
PENTAGON JUST. NOT EVERYONE CAN
AFFORD TO RATE THEIR FOUR ONE K.
TO PAY FOR THE SINGS SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VOTE THANK. YOU
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- DO WE
HAVE ANY- WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SHARE. A LOT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COURCELLES
ELLO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- I WANTED TO JUST TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM YOUR IRRESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE HAS BEEN COMBINED WITH
THE CORONER'S OFFICE WHICH
REMAINS A CHOICE THAT THE COUNTY-BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MAKES
PURSUANT TO CURRENT STATUTE AND
FORTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE MADE
THAT CHOICE OVER THE YEARS. SO
THE VAST MAJORITY OF COUNTIES
HAVE CHOSEN THAT MODEL TEN
COUNTIES HAVE DECIDED THEY DON'T
WANT THAT MODEL OR THAT THEY
WANTED TO CHANGE FROM SHERIFF
CORNER MODEL TO A SEPARATE
CORNER INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
EXAMINER THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO THAT AND THEY'VE DONE THAT.
THE CORNERS EXPERTISE IS
INVESTIGATION AND THAT'S THE
ROLE THEY PLAY THE CORNER DOES
NOT DETERMINE THE CAUSE OF DEATH
THE PHYSICIAN DETERMINES THE
MANNER OF DEATH SKEWS ME THE
CAUSE OF DEATH AND THAT IS THE
CASE IN EVERY DEATH
INVESTIGATION WHERE THERE IS A
CORNER INVOLVED IRRESPECTIVE OF
THE MODEL IF THERE'S AN ELECTED
CORNER A PHYSICIAN DETERMINES
CAUSE OF DEATH IF THERE'S A
SHERIFF CORNER THE PHYSICIAN
DETERMINES THE CAUSE OF DEATH
THE CORNER DETERMINES THE MANNER
OF DEATH NATURAL ACCIDENTAL
SUICIDE HOMICIDE UNDETERMINED
THAT'S THE CORNERS
DETERMINATION. THE CORNERS
EXPERTISE IS INVESTIGATION THE
CORNER DOES NOT MAKE A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS THAT'S THE JOB OF THE
MEDICAL DOCTOR IN EVERY DEATH
INVESTIGATION THAT IS OVERSEEN
BY A CORNER IN EVERY COUNTY
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE GOVERNANCE
MODEL THEY CHOOSE IF THEY HAVE
AN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL EXAMINER
A MEDICAL DOCTOR USUALLY A
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST WITH
SPECIAL TRAINING DOES THE
FORENSIC AUTOPSY THAT'S ALWAYS
THE CASE BUT DOCTOR ALWAYS DOES
THE AUTOPSY SO THIS NOTION THAT
A SHERIFF DOESN'T HAVE MEDICAL
TRAINING. IS ILLUSORY BECAUSE
THE CORNER IS NOT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL FUNCTIONS THE
CORNER DETERMINES MANNER OF
DEATH BASED ON INVESTIGATION OF
THE FACTS SURROUNDING THE
MEDICAL REASONS FOR THE PERSON'S
DEATH. THAT'S IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION IN THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE IT'S- IT. THERE IS THERE
IS NOT A QUESTION ABOUT SHOULD A
UNTRAINED. PERSON WHO IS NOT
TRAINED IN MEDICINE BE MAKING
MEDICAL DECISIONS THAT'S THE
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S AT ISSUE HERE
. THE CURRENT SURE OF CORNER
APPROACH UTILIZED BY CHOICE-
ENJOYS THE BENEFIT OF
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES
SHERIFF'S OFFICES DO
INVESTIGATIONS THAT'S WHAT THE
CORNERS ROLE IS AGAIN THE
PHYSICIAN DETERMINES CAUSE OF
DEATH. IN SAN JOAQUIN THE
EXAMPLE BEARS ARE TWO THINGS ONE
THAT COUNTIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE THEIR DECISION ON HOW
THEY WANT TO HAVE THEIR COUNTY
OFFICES ORGANIZED AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO COMBINE THE
OFFICE OF THE SHERIFF CORNER
THEY HAD COMBINED THOSE OFFICES.
THEY DECIDED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THEY NO LONGER WISH TO HAVE
THOSE OFFICES COMBINED THEY WERE
ABLE TO SEPARATE THEM AT THEIR
CHOICE THEY MADE THE DECISION
BASED ON ALL OF THE FACTORS OF
BARK. AND DECIDED THAT IT WAS
WORTH IT FOR THEIR COUNTY TO
MAKE THAT DECISION TO HAVE A
SEPARATE CORNERS OFFICE. SAN
JOAQUIN ALSO SHOWS THAT THIS
QUESTION OF MANNER OF DEATH. AND
CAUSE OF DEATH. THE MANNER IS
THE CORNERSTONE OF YOU EVEN IF
SEPARATED FROM THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE SO THERE ARE MANY MODELS
AND ELECTED CORNER AN APPOINTED
CORNER. A MEDICAL EXAMINER. AT
THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT THAT
THERE ARE COUNTIES WHO UTILIZES
OPTIONS AND THAT'S THEIR CHOICE.
FROM A GOVERNANCE PERSPECTIVE
THIS BILLS HEAVY HANDED IT
DISREGARDS LOCAL CONTROL-
THERE'S NO MONEY IN THIS BILL.
FOR COUNTIES TO STAND UP
SEPARATE SHARE OF CORNER OFFICES
BUT IT REQUIRES THAT IT BE DONE-
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE MASSIVE
COST THIS WILL CREATE. THERE'S A
QUESTION IN THE ANALYSIS WHETHER
OR NOT THE BILL INTENDS TO UPEND
THE CURRENT FORTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WHO HAVE ELECTED TO USE THE
SHARE OF CORE MODEL. IF IT
DOESN'T THEN THAT'S- VERY
HELPFUL BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR
I DON'T WANNA SPEAK FOR THE
AUTHOR BUT- THAT- THAT SEEMS TO
BE CLEAR WHAT'S- WHAT'S AT ISSUE
HERE. COUNTIES HAVE ADOPTED
PROCEDURES TO ADDRESS PERCEIVED
CONFLICTS WITHOUT DEATH
INVESTIGATIONS ARE UNDERTAKING-
AND THIS BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO
DEATHS INVOLVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT- IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
A PERCEIVD PROBLEM. WITH A
PERCEIVED CONFLICT BETWEEN. A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
INVESTIGATING DEATHS. INVOLVING
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL SAID
JUST SAYS. SHARES CANNOT BE
INVOLVED IN THE DEATH
INVESTIGATION PROCESS
IRRESPECTIVE OF ACCOUNTING
SWITCHES. THE FOR THESE REASONS
WERE RESPECT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CORONERS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT I WILL MIND MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE WITH THE STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION- AND I JUST
WANT TO- REPEAT WHAT IT
ARTICULATELY HAS BEEN SPOKEN BY
THE AUTHORED THAT. GAG COUNTIES
CAN ALREADY DO THIS- WITHOUT A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE AND MANY
HAVE ALREADY ALREADY HAVE DONE
SO- SO WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER OF. WITNESSES HAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THE
MORNING- JULIAN CHRISTIAN
REPRESENT A SEMI CONSCIOUS
APARTMENT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THIRTY CAN ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND ARE OPPOSED
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. OKAY NOW WE NEED TO
OFFER THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND THE ROOM. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS DENNIS QUESTOR
MEADOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE BILL IN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS KRISTOFF
MATTER WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN AWAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AT&T OPERATOR IF
WE COULD HAVE THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS EITHER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ON THE
PHONE THIS IS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU IF YOU
HAVE- SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE MAN ZERO. OUR
FIRST LINE OPEN AT NINE THIRTY
MY NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BY SHARING
MEMBERS CAITLIN DEAN ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT. MAX LEVINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BOBBY ACTRESS
X. ALSO ON B. I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
UNITED FOR JUSTICE AND LOVE NOT
THAT CAMPAIGN I EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE SIX OH
EIGHT. THANK YOU. RIGHT NUMBER
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARY BETH I'M
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL LINES FOR FILIPINO
CONCERNS WHICH IS A MEMBER
ORGANIZATION OF THE JUSTICE FOR
AND TO LOOK INTO THAT FOR OUR
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IN THE
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR IT. YOU
KNOW IT THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A
THAT AND LEGISLATIVE AIDE FOR
SOMEONE WALTON PRESIDENT OF THE
TEXAS TO SCRAMBLE TO SUPERVISORS
AND I'M CALLING AT THE PORTS.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FORTY FOUR.
BRIAN HOPE FOR ON BEHALF OF CO
SPONSORS SECURE JUSTICE HERE IN
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATION'S AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL
OF US ARE NON INITIATE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER STATION ACTION EAST BAY
DENMARK AREA. HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FORTY TWO. BY NUMBER FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL BE ON
THE LINE FIFTY ONE LINE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME SO MY NAME IS
DIANE TO DOES NOT I'M CALLING-
BEHALF OF I AM STUCK FOUNDATION
AND I'M CALLING- KILEY THEY HAVE
A PARTY FOR NOW FAMILY UNITED
FOR DISTANCE. I'M EXPRESSING MY
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SIX OR EIGHT
DONE EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR IT.
MY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THIRTY FIVE. MORNING
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE FIFTY TWO.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RANDY PERRY
WITH OR ACT IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. MY NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NUMBER TWENTY. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DEANNA CALLED
SQUINTING I AM ONE OF AND YOU
LOOK INTO TO OUR A AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NO EIGHT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINE FORTY THREE. MEMBERS
I'D LIKE UNRAVELED ON
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NUMBER THIRTY
TWO. HI THIS IS TERRY VALEN AND
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY CENTER AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PART OF THE
JUSTICE FOR ANGELO CAN GO
JUSTICE FOR ALL COALITION. IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN OH EIGHT- THE
FAMILY HAS BEEN SEEKING JUSTICE
AND LEADING THE- FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE FOR ANGELO CAN TELL.
NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY AND WE'RE
HERE TO STAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THEM AND THAT PARTICULAR BILL
TO SEPARATE THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
FROM THE CORONER'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING- ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MY NAME IS JOHN DR
JONATHAN LUCAS ON THE CHIEF
MEDICAL JENNIFER LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF. AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT. BY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWENTY THREE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE AB SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT PROUD CO SPONSOR THANK YOU
. BY NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TWENTY TWO. MY NAME IS
MARIA REYNOLDS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NOISE. THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FORTY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS JACQUELINE GALLAGHER AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
BROTHER CHRISTOPHER VALIDATED IT
WAS MURDERED BY RIALTO POLICE
I'M CALLING IN THE BOARDING
GATE. KNOWING THAT MY FAMILY WAS
IMPACTED BRADLEY- LIKE THIS NEED
TO BE IN. UNDER COUNTY SEPARATE
AND MEDICAL. YOUR MY NUMBER
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FIFTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
JULIE WATER AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIFTY SEVEN.
I AM DANIEL RODHAM CALLING ON
BEHALF. OF THE AS WELL IN MY
FAMILY AND CRICKET RATHER THAN
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT AB ONE THE LADY ON THE
IMPACT FAMILY MEMBER AND WE HAVE
LOTS SOMEONE GETS TO BELIEVE THE
KILEY AS THEY. MS FINALLY FOUND
THEMSELVES BECAUSE WE THE ALARM
THAT THE YOU CAN WITHIN THEIR
OWN TO. RIGHT WHAT IS A JUST YES
IT. THANK YOU. AT OUR LAST FIND
OPEN A MY NUMBER LINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALL OF THESE OF YOUR
REAL. QUICK BECAUSE- ONE THREE
MURDERED I AM CALLING SUPPORT A
GET NBC GOING PASSED MOTHER
SHOULD LOOK THEIR SON. BUT A
YOUNG AGE TWO BILLION FOR TELL
MARC DID AND THE THIRD JUST.
THREE I'M GOING COULD
INVESTIGATED AND UNDER. TELL ME
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
FEW AND HAVE WELL NUMBERS NEARLY
ALL. YES MY NAME IS MICHAEL ON
THE HOW OF CAL FOUND UNITED
SUGGESTS WE STRONGLY. A. B. OH
EIGHT AND HAVE PRO OUR PROUD CO
SPONSOR TO THAT. AND THERE'S
ANOTHER PERSON AND YOU WILL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT.
MY NUMBER SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE SIXTY TWO. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO LINE IS OPEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY HELLO MY NAME IS
MARIE CALL SINGLE AND I'M
CALLING IN THE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR JUSTICE
I EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR AB
SIXTY NOTE EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND
MY NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
HOW DO ON A RESIDENTS FROM
DANVILLE IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIXTEEN OH EIGHT.
SEPARATE THE DUTIES OF THE
SHERATON CORNER NO ONE OFFICER
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD HAVE SUCH A
CONCENTRATION OF POWER ERODES
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE AND TRUST.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE THANK
YOU ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE WILL NOW HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE ANY. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE WILL GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
LET ME- JUST SIMPLY SAY WE
CANNOT WAIT- UNTIL. OF SOMETHING
HAPPENS TO SPEAK WE'RE SPEAKING
LOUD AND CLEAR. I WANT TO THANK
THOSE WHO'VE CALLED IN THOSE WHO
SPONSOR THIS BILL COSPONSORED
THIS BILL THOSE WHO. WHO GAVE UP
THEIR TIME TO- PROVIDE THEIR
SUPPORT- IN SUPPORTING SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT REALLY MEANS A GREAT
DEAL- TO THE ANGELO COLLINS
FAMILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMON. REALIZING THAT
IT'S TOUGH- AS A FAMILY WHO'S
BEEN IMPACTED- DUE TO A LOSS OF
A LOVED ONE- WITH QUESTIONABLE-
DETERMINATION WHETHER NOT HOW
THE INDIVIDUAL PASSED- MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
STANDING- DR MITCHELL AND ALSO
MISTER ROOM ARE AMERITECH YOU
VERY MUCH. LET ME JUST SIMPLY
SAY THIS THAT- THE SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT BUILT UPON THE WORK THAT
I'VE DONE AROUND AB- FOR NINETY
DELUDE POSITIONAL EXIA. I HAVE-
CONCLUDED AND HAVEN'T WOULD NAME
THIS BILL AFTER THE ANGELO AND
LOOKING TO ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWO TO SAY IS NAME IS
AND- THAT HE IS NOT FORGOTTEN.
AND WE DO THIS WORK BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT ONE THAT THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND THE
CORONER'S OFFICE SHOULD BE
SEPARATED AND WE DO THIS AND WE
SPEAK THIS WAY- TWO ONE TO
PROVIDE CLARITY- NOW IF HEART
AND NOT THOUGHT OF MINE. TO
SIMPLY SAY THAT WE WANT TO
REMOVE ANY KIND OF APPEARANCE OF
IMPROPRIETY WE WILL REMOVE ANY
KIND OF AND- APPEARANCE OF BIAS
THIS WE BELIEVE WHEN A PATH A- A
DOCTOR. WHO PERFORMING AUTOPSY
HE PICKS OR FIX HER NAME ON THE
DEED. IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS.
BECAUSE WHAT THEY CAN GET AS THE
MEDICAL EXAMINER- IN TERMS OF
THE CAUSE OF DEATH I HAVE
ALREADY INDICATED IN
ARTICULATED- THAT SHERIFF-
OVERSEEING SUCH DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T HAVE THE SKILL THAT THE
CERTIFICATION OR THE MEDICAL
EXPERTISE. TO OVERSEE SUCH.
DEPARTMENT IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU
SING ME OVER A CARDIO. TO I HAVE
NO X. NO X. IS NOWHERE. TO
EITHER AND CONCLUDE OR TO EVEN.
ADD AN OPINION ON SOMETHING THAT
I'M NOT EVEN SKILLFUL IN AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE WEST WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW-
BIFURCATING THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND THE CORONER'S
OFFICE HAVE THE CORNER STANDS
ALONE. WIND CORNERS OFFICE
STANDS ALONE- THEY'RE NOT
RECEIVING THE PRESSURE I
INDICATED ABOUT WHAT TRANSPIRED
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY DURING THE
DURING THE AUDIT WE HAVE THE
INDIVIDUAL HERE TODAY WHO
TESTIFIED DR MITCHELL. ABOUT HIS
AUDIT HIS CONCLUSION AND AS A
RESULT THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THEMSELVES
BIFURCATING SEPARATED THE
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE OF WHAT
TRANSPIRED BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS
INVESTIGATED BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS
CONCLUDED. DURING THAT LONG
INVESTIGATION THAT PEOPLE
RESIGNED AND REYES RESIGNED
THEIR POSITION AND THEY KNOW
COULD NO LONGER MOVE FORWARD AND
SO SIMPLY SAYING INNOCENTLY BILL
SIX NO EIGHT WILL PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH THE PEACE OF MIND
UNDERSCORE PEACE OF MIND- WHEN
IT COMES DOWN TO CAUSE A DEATH
INVESTIGATION. AND THE PROCESS I
HAVE BEEN DONE- BY MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE THAT THEY CAN
STAND BY WITHOUT ANY KIND OF
INFLUENCE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE LET
CALIFORNIA JOINED THE OTHER
STATES. WHO HAVE ALREADY
SEPARATED THE CORONER'S OFFICE
FROM THE SERVICE DEPARTMENT. AND
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. FIRST
OF ALL WE NEED TO MOTIONS SECOND
BECAUSE OF A- THANK YOU CAME TO
BE ABLE TO. AGUIAR-CURRY WAIT
JUST A MOMENT WHICH IS MORE
ABOUT DANIEL. I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SOME SOME REMARKS REAL QUICKLY-
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE A SENSE OF
DUTY SINCE I'M THE ONLY ONE IN
THIS COMMITTEE THAT'S ACTUALLY.
DEALT WITH CORNERS AND CAUSE OF
DEATH AND AUTOPSIES. I'VE BEEN
PRESENT WHEN THESE TAKE PLACE. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING. IN
MY LIFE EXPERIENCES MORE
DELICATE. THE WHEN SOMEONE LOSES
THEIR LIFE NO MATTER WHAT. AND
WHAT YOU HAVE IS HIGH HIGH HIGH
MOTION. AND THAT SHOULD BE
UNDERSTOOD. WHAT TALK ABOUT
BIFURCATING. THE BIFURCATION
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
UNDERSTOOD. IS THE ROLE OF THE
CORNER VERSUS A MEDICAL DOCTOR
THERE'S A VERY DISTINCT
DIFFERENCE. ONE ANNOUNCES MANNER
OF DEATH. THE MEDICAL DOCTOR NOT
THE CORNER THE MEDICAL DOCTOR IS
THE ONE WHO ISSUES THE RULING ON
CAUSE OF DEATH. THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION EVERYONE.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD REMIND
YOU. THIS IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN MAKE THIS CALL
FORTY EIGHT COUNTIES. HAVE MADE
THE DECISION THAT THEY WANT TO
MERGE. THE COOPERATION BETWEEN
THESE TWO ENTITIES. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IT'S IN OUR BEST
JUDGMENT TO BIG BROTHER. THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN ELECTED BY THEIR
LOCAL PEOPLE TO MAKE THIS
DECISION. SO I WILL
UNFORTUNATELY NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. IN CONTRAST-
WE ARE CHAIR IS NOT HERE BUT I
AM GOING TO READ YOU ADD WHAT
SHE WOULD LIKE TO SAY. AND THOSE
THESE ARE HER HER REMARKS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL.
WHILE I'M SYMPATHETIC TO
CONCERNS RAISED BY OPPONENTS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE COST IMPACTS ON SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS. I RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR DISTRICTS SEPARATION OF
DUTIES BETWEEN THE SHERIFF OR
CORONER PARTICULARLY WHEN A
DEATH OCCURS THAT INVOLVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SHE WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AND
THE COURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH OPPONENTS TO
ADDRESS. ISSUES WITH THE ISSUES
THEY HAVE RAISED. THE MOTION IS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY NO LATINO
BLOOM. BLOOM HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH ALL RIGHT WELL
LOS. REBELS NOT VOTING
THREE OF US. THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL THE BILL
PELL NOW. YOUR VOTE IS CURRENTLY
THREE TWO. OKAY WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN ALSO AND WE'LL LET YOU
KNOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU COMMITTEE. THIS IS A MEMBER
BENNETT PRESIDENT. YES YES. AND
FOR. OKAY I DON'T FOR SOME
RENDON'S. AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
THREE. YOU MAY PROCEED. I DON'T
THINK I'LL START WITH THE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR OKAY- BUT-
GOOD MORNING- VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS- AB AT TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
THREE SIMPLY PROVIDES THE VOTERS
OF VENTURA COUNTY THE ABILITY TO
RAISE A TRANSACTION USED TAX TO
PROVIDE FOR MORE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING OF THE BILL DOES NOT
INCREASE THE TAX ITSELF THAT
DISCRETION CONTINUES TO REMAIN
WITH THE VOTERS OF- VENTURA
COUNTY UNDER EXISTING LAW CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE AUTHORIZED TO
IMPOSE. TRANSACTION A USE TAX
INCREASES IN QUARTER SANTA
INCREMENTS AS LONG AS A COMBINED
RATE IN THE COUNTY DOES NOT
EXCEED TWO PERCENT- BUT WITH ONE
CITY HAS EXCEEDED THAT- LEVEL
THAN ALL OF THE OTHER CITIES IN
THE COUNTY OR IMPEDED FROM
MOVING FORWARD OTHER VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RECENTLY PASSED A RESOLUTION-
REQUESTING THE LEGISLATIVE.
TRAINING- ELIQUIS TO RAY THEIR
CAP- INVENTOR COUNTY THE
AUTHORIZATION FOR TERRA
TRANSPORTATION TAX INCREASE REST
WEST OF INTER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
COMMITTEE COMMISSION. AND SO THE
REASON AMENDMENTS REFLECT THAT
AUTHORIZATION I WILL NOTE THAT
OF WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
GRANTED SEVERAL EXEMPTIONS THE
2% CAP IN RECENT YEARS FOR A
NUMBER OF LOCALITIES THAT HAVE
MADE THAT REQUEST- WITH ME
TODAY- VENTURA COUNTY SUPERVISOR
MATT LAVERE- AND- CANDY FIELDS-
WHO WILL BE REPRESENTING A TIM
CRIMMINS- FROM THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS- I REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- AS MR
BENNETT SAID MY NAME IS NOT LIVE
HERE AND HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING- THE RESIDENTS THE
FIRST DISTRICT ON THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND
I APPRECIATE YOU GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENEFITS BILL AB TWO FOUR
FIVE THREE- IF INTER COUNTY
WE'VE BEEN VERY JUDICIOUS ABOUT
TAXING OURSELVES WE ONLY DO IT.
WHEN CRITICALLY NECESSARY TO IT
TOO TO FIND QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES- AND YOU KNOW NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE CORE SERVICES-
CURRENTLY AT RISK COMMUNITIES
AROUND US HAS A SELF HELP TAX-
BUT AS IT STANDS TODAY THE INTER
COUNTY. IS LOSING OUT ON
SIGNIFICANT STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE A
SIMILAR A SELF HELP MEASURE IN
OUR COUNTY AND THAT'S WHY AB TWO
FOUR FIVE THREE SO IMPORTANT TO
THE RESIDENTS OF INTER COUNTY-
IN ONE OF OUR- IN WHICH I
REPRESENT ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. HIGHS NEAR THE TOP%
OF THE CAP AND EFFECTIVELY
PREVENTS THE RESIDENTS OF THE
ENTIRE COUNTY- FROM PASSING A
SELF. A SELF HELP TAX MEASURE NO
MATTER HOW POPULAR MAYBE.
PUBLICLY AND AB TWO FOUR FIVE
THREE FIXES THAT PROBLEM-
PROVIDES NOMINAL TAX CATHOLIC
ONLY POINT FIVE PERCENT- BUT
THIS WILL GIVE THE- RESIDENTS A
VENTURA COUNTY DEBILITY. TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO PASS. A SELF
HELP MEASURE. AND THAT'S REALLY
ALL I'M HERE FOR TODAY- IS THIS
IDEA OF SELF DETERMINATION AND
THE RIGHT FOR OUR LOCAL
RESIDENTS TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER OR NOT- TO.
WHAT THE FUTURE OF
TRANSPORTATION WILL LOOK LIKE IN
VENTURA COUNTY- AND YOU ASKED MR
BENNETT SAID- MY BOARD. VOTED
BIPARTISAN FASHION- SUPERVISOR
KELLY LONG SUPERVISOR CARMEN
REARS REPAIRS REPUBLICAN
DEMOCRAT THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
VOTE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
IT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY. ON
BEHALF OF THE RESIDENTS OF INTER
COUNTY AYE I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR PLIGHT. AND I
WOULD HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. OKAY
WITNESSES GO AHEAD IN THE ROOM
YES THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
MY NAME IS IN YOUR FIELDS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF TIM
CRIMMINS AND HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN OF THEOPERATING
ENGINEERS AS WELL AS THE VENTURA
COUNTY FIRST COMMITTING A
FUNDING INNOVATIVE RELIABLE AND
SAFE TRANSPORTATION WE URGE- AND
I GAVE BOTH AND AGAIN THINK OF
ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT FOR A
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL BRING AN
ECONOMIC BOON TO VENTURA COUNTY
AND INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF JOBS
THAT WE CAN HAVE FOR THE HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN. OF OUR
LABOR- OF OUR OF OUR OF OUR
LABOR UNIONS- THE TURF COUNTY
COUNTY FIRST COMMITTEE IS MADE
UP OF- NOT ONLY LABOR BUT ALSO A
LOCAL BUSINESSES-
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND WE URGE ENABLE. A
GAVE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. SAYING NINE GO AHEAD
AND HAVE THE- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF WE HAVE ANY.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ANY.
WELL NOW AS EVERYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO. THE CALLERS A.
T. AN T. OPERATOR IF WE COULD-
HAVE THOSE WHO ARE WAITING ON
THE PHONES EXPRESSED THEIR USE
OF THEIR SUPPORT OR THEIR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU LINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINE FORTY EIGHT. LINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO RECORD THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU THIS IS CHALLENGING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES. GOOD QUESTION
FOR THE COMMITTEE. OKAY WE HAVE
A FIRST AND SECOND FEDERAL RADIO
THE WORDS FROM THE CHAIR SHE
SAYS THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING.
YOUR BILL TODAY SHE SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS TO GIVE FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE TO HELP SOLVE ITS LOCAL
FUNDING CHALLENGES MOTION IS.
DUE PASSED TO THE REVENUE AND
TAX COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY LAGI
. NO MACHENAUD BLOOM. I WILL HI
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
NOT VOTING RAMOS RAMOS HI THIS
RIVAS THREE OF US AYE
ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO.
THREE TWO. OKAY WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN. AND WILL ANNOUNCE THE
OUTCOME BASED ON THE VOTE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
THE SECOND. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY HI
LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM HI
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
HI ROB LOS ROBLES HI LAS VEGAS
THREE OF US I WEBER REAVIS.
VOEPEL. I WILL TELL HI. SIXTY
OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN AND
- THE REST OF YOUR I GUESS WE'RE
DONE.
YEAH.
OKAY. ONE THREE WOMEN WHO CAN
JUST GO RIGHT THROUGH THIS
PLEASE CALENDAR THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I-
SENSE OUT EIGHT ZERO AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT THE VOTERS CURRENTLY
FOR TWO. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I THAT IS FIVE TWO
THOUSAND- AND THAT'S WHAT THE-
SIX ZERO EIGHT SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
IS OUT FIVE TO. AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY THREE BENNETT THE VOTERS
CURRENTLY FOR TWO AGUIAR-CURRY
HI COOLEY I. BY TWO BILLS OUT SB. TWO TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE
FIVE TWO. AND THAT'S IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY AND WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.